boys girls i hope you're doing well you
know one of the interesting things about
youtube is my favorite type of content
is when other youtubers talk kind of
they break the fourth wall talk about
their inner thoughts talk about
what they've been going through but
myself i always find that to be so
uninteresting on camera we're gonna try
it anyways and look if it doesn't work
hey
we can just pretend this episode never
happened you and i won't speak of this
again we'll just this will be one of the
great lost episodes of coffeezilla we'll
remove it we'll banish it to the shadow
realm
and uh we'll just move on with their
life okay but i want to tell you guys
something i've been thinking about and
it came from a conversation with graham
steffen look you guys know i had him on
my podcast
the drip fridays and he told me he came
on my live stream and told me not to
live stream anymore
one of the things i'll just tell you
from one of the things that i think
you're doing wrong from a growth
perspective is doing
live streams long live streams like this
lower the overall click-through rate
so very few people are unlike very few
people are likely to go back and watch
your live stream
so youtube sees that as a a disa like
like a not very performing video
so he says look just move the live
stream to a different channel
what would be better for you to do right
is you want to do live streams
make a second channel for that and i
think he's right i'm gonna try it out
i'm gonna try it for like a month
see if i see any difference if not we'll
move it back to the channel
but if you're a fan of the the live
stream you should know we're moving it
to
the drip it's a youtube channel all on
its own i'm going to leave it
first link in the description go
subscribe if you want to continue to be
kept up to date with that
because here going forward we're not
having it hosted here
on coffeezilla so go subscribe to the
drip we're going to have great guests we
got philip solo tv coming on it's gonna
be epic
but that conversation got me thinking
about something larger
which is change it's been a thing i've
been like experiencing i'm talking to my
friends a lot recently
a lot of my creator friends are feeling
burnt out tired of the content they're
producing tired of
you know repeating themselves tired of
doing the same thing
and i wanted to put this out there maybe
even for myself a little bit
and some of you at home who are
wondering you know what you should do if
you're facing kind of a crossroads
i think life is about embracing change
which might sound a little cliche to say
but coupled with change is the fear and
possibility of failure so really what
i'm saying
is that life is about embracing failure
that's definitely been true of my life i
don't know if you guys know but
even the people who've been riding with
me since coffee break days
like i've tried so many things on
youtube
even prior to that you know i've had a
piano channel i've had a twitch channel
where i get five viewers
you know every night and i'd stream for
like three hours the channel
never took off it died it was a terrible
idea from the start
you know i ran an interview show that
was like the start of coffeezilla was an
interview show i was going to interview
video essayists
i was sure it was the next big thing
that totally bombed but
i realized throwing those things against
the wall and seeing them
fail actually is what caused me to get
to where i
am today and i couldn't have gotten here
without basically
making a series of failures that you
know blew up in my face they bombed at
the time
and i think that's what everyone misses
they want to shortcut success
they want to avoid failure and that's
what keeps them from changing is because
they think that by being smart they can
dodge
failure but i don't think you can i
think it's the failures
that make the successes not the other
way around it's not like you endure
failure until you hit success no the
failure helps you learn how to be
successful
so i wanted to say to you guys don't be
afraid about
failing with change because you probably
will like honestly
most of the things that i've tried on
this platform have bombed
but nobody ever remembers the bombs
nobody ever remembers the fails
the well maybe you guys do a little bit
but we can just make it an inside joke
that's fine but the point is at the end
of the day people forget about that
stuff and they just remember
what you end up succeeding at and that's
something that i think about a lot
you know i read this book called made in
america by sam walton's the guy who
you know made walmart and one of the
really interesting things about him
is like his biggest character trait that
i think made him successful
was he was obsessed with learning from
his competitors
and just from people in general like in
the book he's at the top of his game
he's you know the king of walmart his
stores everywhere
and he's still going into other people's
grocery stores
and like looking at what are they doing
what are they doing successfully what
are they doing better than me
he's like measuring the distance between
their stalls because he likes the flow
of traffic better
than at his walmart i mean his obsession
with growth
never stopped even when he was at the
top even when he could have gotten
complacent or he could be thinking you
know i'm at the top i have the most to
lose by changing and
failing and that's the thing that
impressed me the most
is just his attitude towards change and
it's what i try to do as well dude i
sound like
i sound like an inspirational guru right
now i swear i'm not this is just
actually true
this is really what i believe about the
world is that um when you stop
trying new things is the exact second
that you stop
getting better you stop growing and i've
seen so many other youtubers do it like
you see them grow and when they get that
big audience
you see them get paralyzed i know you
guys can think of one or two creators
right now who this has happened to
and they just keep doing the same
content that got them successful five
years ago
because they're simply afraid to grow
they're afraid to you know stop doing
what has always worked for them
and i think you can't be afraid of that
and that's really something i try to
remember
and it's what i think about when graham
gives me advice like that hey stop live
streaming
maybe he's right let's try it out let's
move it to another channel for 30 days
what's the harm
worst thing that happens it flops
honestly nobody's gonna remember it
five months from now no one's gonna
remember that we took a month to go put
it on the other channel
it doesn't matter so i don't know if
there's some of you out here there that
need to hear this advice right now
i know i definitely need to be reminded
of it sometimes so um
yeah i hope you guys enjoyed this little
rant that's what i've been thinking
about
uh how you can change big and small
because let me give you a little secret
we're about to make a big change the the
live streaming is a small thing
we're on the come up of a big change
with the 10 million dollar studio about
to be completed i know i've been talking
about it forever guys it's
around the corner before the new year i
think we'll have it for you guys
but we're about to make a giant change
to content and i hope you guys roll with
me on that because i promise you one
thing
i won't stop trying to improve we won't
stop
making this community better more fun
have bigger and better videos for you
guys
um so thanks for riding with me so far
guys i i hope we can go even further see
you next time
as always smash like and subscribe thank
you